The level of discussion on The David Pakman
Show show lately has been very, very high
and I mean a lot.
Hi.
To quote our president.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it.
A user named J-P Denise's posted a very interesting
comparison of the policies of Bernie Sanders,
Joe Biden and Donald Trump to try to make
clear that there is really not very much in
common between Biden and Trump and quite a
bit in common between Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders.
And I think it's important for us to understand.
I mean, listen, I don't think it's useful
to pretend that Joe Biden is something he
isn't.
And that applies to both sides.
Joe Biden is not Bernie Sanders.
Joe Biden is not a progressive.
Joe Biden is not going to push for nearly
every policy that Bernie Sanders was pushing
for.
But Joe Biden is way closer to Bernie than
he is to Donald Trump.
And whether you look at the minimum wage,
paid family leave, Citizens United, the death
penalty, prison sentencing related to drugs,
abortion rights, capital gains taxes, wealth
taxes, the climate, nuclear power, you actually
see that Bernie and Trump are both no's, sort
of.
And Biden is a yes.
So in any case, that's not bragging about
Biden's position.
But the point is, if we say Biden's more like
Trump than Bernie, we are just very, very
wrong.
I want people deciding on the facts.
If you think that we are better off with Trump
than Biden, then vote that way.
But don't be tricked into making a move that
helps Trump because you incorrectly believe
that Biden and Trump share significant policy
when really the vast majority of the shared
policy is between Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders.
To different degrees on many issues.
Decide however you want, but I want you to
decide with the facts, not with incorrect
talking points.
So a very good post by JP Denise's L Bun Zaino
posted Is David overusing the word weaponized?
And a lot of people in the response is saying
this seems like a weird thing to be concerned
about and it's an appropriate word to be using.
Yeah, my my use of the word weaponized has
definitely increased lately because we are
seeing so much weaponisation by the government.
Donald Trump has webpack weaponized disinformation.
Donald Trump has weaponized his delusions
of grandeur.
Donald Trump has weaponized his own and his
followers, ignorance and gullibility.
We are seeing a level of weaponisation both
by Donald Trump and by right wing media that
carries water for him.
That is like nothing I've ever seen.
And I was actually watching.
I went on YouTube and I found some clips of
Fox News covering George W. Bush's presidency.
And of course, you know, it's the normal playbook.
How do you support a standard Republican president
if you are standard right wing media?
And it almost seemed quaint compared to the
degree of weaponization that we are seeing
today.
It's not a defensive George W. Bush and it's
not a defensive Fox News.
It is merely a shocking realization I came
to of how far things have slid since the George
W. Bush Fox News era to the Trump Fox News
0a n phase in which we now find ourselves.
Lastly, user turkey, bacon and cheese posted
to the Reddit Pedro Call Appreciation writing.
I just want to say that the Pedro part of
the show was hilarious.
A nice change in mood and worth the time he
wasted.
Thanks for the laugh.
Yeah, I actually I got an email from someone
claiming to be Pedro over the weekend.
With what they claimed was a picture of them
and it was just a drawing of a completely
stereotypical Mexican man, and it struck me
as incredibly offensive to to some degree
and also hilarious because Pedro claims to
be Colombian.
But the drawing was of what you would see
as a stereotypical Mexican like mariachi guy.
It's crazy.
The entire Pedro Arc is taking on a life of
its own.
But I'm glad people are getting some enjoyment
out of it in these otherwise very dark times.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it.